is there one place that you would not
want to see any star wars stuff
wow
that would be
our bed
no star wars things in our bed
not even with me in costume oh maybe
[Music]
it started when i was in primary one
then my dad
promised that if i did well for my exams
he would buy me every star wars figure
there was he took a trolley
and he took down every single
figure and vehicle that was on the shelf
i think he spent about 200
that was a pretty big deal from that day
on
everything else was history the
collection started from there
[Music]
my name is jasper and i'm 47 years old
this year i'm a hr director in an
agri-food firm
i'm a true blue star wars fan anything
star wars is good
so i'm not here to say that movie was
bad or this movie was better
the interesting thing about the the star
wars movie franchise is that they
refresh
and give a new perspective to the
original stuff that we once loved in the
past we didn't really take notice of the
bounty hunter ig-88 but in mandalorian
we got to love him same with the ognot
in the carbonite chamber but in
mandalorian he became a very lovable
character
and of course the different iterations
of boba fett
from return of the jedi to a short
glimpse where cop van was wearing his
armor to now the latest dead bod boba
using the same icons they managed to
refresh it and to give it a more that
character is not dead there is still
more to him
and i think that that really helps the
continuity of it
to and also for it to transcend
generations you know we don't want to be
stuck seeing the same
characters but we want to see the
characters grow and i think that the
franchise has done pretty well in that
respect the first item i actually
unboxed was a raid gut
figure you know when you play with toys
there will be always a king
kind of figure and i thought the red guy
was so cool because he had a real cloth
cape and his face was so
menacingly simple i wouldn't say that
i'm a collector in that i don't go for
limited edition or signature edition
items i think this collection here is is
my my pride and joy as i walk past you
know i always stop to just take a look
again even though i'm seeing this every
day but it just brings me joy to just
look at
one particular helmet closer and all
that
what excites me about the next item that
i want to get is the process of actually
what i would be doing to build it or to
customize it or to make it screen
accurate so that actually makes my
decision as to which item i want to get
next
well in the past we didn't have the
internet yes i'm that old
and so it was really playing back vhs
tapes pausing at that scene
to try and have a closer look at what
the costume was or that prop was
and then when the internet came about
there was a lot more information
available
and
right now you know with disney plus you
can really go 4k pause
and really do your research
there are also a lot of communities out
there in the forums that actually help
to identify some of these screen use
props the difficulty is not finding the
information but the difficulty is
finding that item itself again after 40
over years the latest addition is of
course hunting carbonite a lot of effort
was put in to
replicate screen use items on the prop
and so the volvo panel that's used for
hunting carbonite was a found item from
a 1976
volvo 343 bl car
you know so they took the the dashboard
and they flipped it around and then
that's the eight panels you see on the
side of it what was used was easy
because the internet provided that
information
sourcing that took me maybe two three
years
until i finally saw somebody posted that
item on ebay
and
yup without looking it's a buy it now
step for me immediately
and when it first arrived
it was amazing to be holding that
dashboard says yeah boy they really you
know this is it this was the panel that
they used to make that and
it has
a lot of meaning for me because this is
not a project that i did on my own i
think my wife helped me build it and and
it's amazing what she had to go through
you know getting your hands dirty with
20 layers of pva glue
you know
covering yourself in in dust sanders and
and paint dust and i think that has that
special meaning
that it's not just a recreation of han
but you know it's i think one of the
first props that i didn't build by
myself but my wife joined in i must say
that the carbonite material is a lot
more exaggerated than the original prop
that was creative license used by me
because i wanted that texture to
to come out more well my collection made
many changes over the years
i
used to have figures collection from the
original canner figures
till
i had the 1 6
scale
and then there were also the premium
format figures
and then there were a whole host of
resin spaceships
right now what sparks joy is actually a
life-size weapons wall for me
and so for that to happen i had to
actually give up some parts of my older
collection proceeds actually went to
charity so that was a good send-off for
that collection that i have
in order for me to start
on this next focus which is actually the
weapons wall
i think the collection has
been a little bit more focused over the
last couple of years and i think
i'm beginning to find that the focus is
correct which is actually real-world
life-size props
at one to one scale
and since i can't have full costumes of
each of these figures i have decided
that the focus will remain on helmets
and weapons
blasters and
the actual items that were used in the
movies for example han solo's dice
the wooden stormtrooper doll in
rogue one the piece of basket steel that
was used in mandalorians so this
actually it became more interesting to
say that hey you know it's actually not
a skilled replica
but more of this was actually a replica
of the prop that was actually used in
the movie so moving forward i can't see
myself having a very different focus
other than finding a plot of land and
building the entire millennium falcon at
my house
i am a member of the 501st legion
singapore garrison so we are costuming
group a star wars costuming group we
have like this first order stormtrooper
suit here is my current costume we wear
the costume out at events places where
people want us to appear
like birthday parties or weddings and
there's also a charity element behind it
you know we we go out and that's why the
tagline for us is actually bad guys
doing good you know so there's a charity
element and that's us having fun in our
star wars costumes i've been involved in
this um i think for more than ten years
and
with that with that exposure to my
family who joins me at some of these
events they get to see what a fun
community it is how we actually have
very good camaraderie with the other
troopers the other costumers and the
kind of excitement we get into when we
put on our costumes
and us interacting with the public i
think that also sparks
a very
community
excitement and interest in in my wife
and son i don't think
you can ever find people who like
exactly the same things you do so if i
like star wars and my family doesn't it
doesn't matter but
what i appreciate is that they accept
that i like star wars and they try to
tie in
with that acceptance my son likes
pokemon alex likes pokemon i don't think
i like it
no offense to him but i will appreciate
that he likes it and i will tie in my
activities with his love for pokemon so
for example they will follow me when i
when i make my costume trooping with my
friends they join in and after a while
they also find hey you know i want to do
this too and that's why my son got his
own costume and subsequently now my wife
has her own costume so i think that's
how it all began and i think the
journey's not ended there's still a long
way more to go i think i just hope that
my wife's costume collection don't
overpass my india
[Music]
i wouldn't change anything about this
styles collection i like it
just as it is okay maybe add more to the
collection
for fiverr first my costume is
a shadow biker scout
and if we get the chance in space maybe
we could create a like pokemon speeder
bike or something
okay
well it actually started from a long
time ago i knew that this was a passion
of his
and
you know we were very blessed to be able
to have this house so and yet so many
things to put up right
so this display here it worked out
really nicely just an opportunity for
him to do what he loves
show case what he has
and you know it makes him happy so
why not
[Laughter]
what was the one thing that jasper did
and sealed the deal
he bought the house on my birthday
it's a birthday present so it's like
anything you want
is there one place that you would not
want to see any star wars stuff
wow
that would be
our bed
no star wars things in our bed
not even with me in costume
oh maybe
[Music]
so what does star wars mean for me other
than it being the
greatest movies ever produced in my life
when they produce star wars though they
were trying to represent the key issues
that was happening in those times in the
70s and the 80s and i think those issues
had transcended time
to today we are still struggling with
the same
issues of right versus wrong
adventure
friendship making hard decisions
that to me is still very relevant today
and it is an extension of my imagination
you know you see a lot of these same
concepts still being featured in the
world we live in today so i think it's
timeless i think these kind of concepts
don't go away
and uh it has helped shape
the way i view the world it has helped
shape
the way i actually make decisions
sometimes
people who say you know what would jesus
do i would probably say you know what
would vader do you know in situations
such as these so i think it is still
relevant i don't think i can define
uh
the meaning of star wars in in that few
sentences but i think it is a lot deeper
and broader
than that and i don't think i see an end
to how star wars will continue to have
meaning in my life
[Music]